we have news from Donald Trump's 2020
campaign and the reason that it's news
from the campaign instead of the
administration has everything to do with
the First Amendment and I'll explain
that to you in a second I guess Trump
sort of riding high on his own
determination that he has been totally
and completely exonerated by William
bars summary of the Moller summary of
the Muller investigation Trump's
campaign for re-election has published a
memo to media outlets demanding that
certain people be blacklisted all of the
people happen to be critics of Donald
Trump they sent out this memo with the
subject line credibility of certain
guests and they pointed out that there
are people who have appeared on
television throughout the course of
special counsel counsel
Robert Mulder's investigation and said
things that Donald Trump doesn't like
and what the Trump campaign is now
asking of television producers is that
they not invite these people back on to
their programs and they actually provide
a list of people who should be
blacklisted that list includes Senator
Richard Blumenthal it includes
congressman Adam Schiff by the way I
have it I totally forgot to mention this
when I went to DC last weekend I went to
lunch at a particular place and I turn
around and Adam Schiff is standing right
behind me having a meal with someone and
if I told you what he ordered you would
all be shocked no I actually I wasn't
sitting close enough to see what he
ordered but he seemed to be enjoying it
anyway congressman Adam Schiff the Trump
campaign doesn't want invited back on
programs congressman Jerrold Nadler
Congressman Eric's wawel DNC chair Tom
Perez former CIA director John Brennan
the Trump 2020 campaign is directing
news producers to not have these people
on and as they say they want news
producers to consider whether any of
those people should be allowed back on
on the basis of having spread what they
call incorrect information which is
hilarious because if news producers
literally follow that you can't have
anybody on or you shouldn't have anybody
on
who has spread misinformation and
disinformation everyone on Fox News
would need to be fired immediately and
Trump himself wouldn't be allowed back
on any programs now this gets back to
the First Amendment thing that I
mentioned at the beginning of the
segment there is a reason why this
letter was released by the Trump
twenty20 campaign rather than the Trump
Whitehouse it's so that they can't say
that this is the government attempting
to censor on or control media when the
Trump campaign publishes this memo they
can say it's a recommendation from a
political campaign okay this is not
government censoring or trying to censor
any voices
if the Trump White House releases such a
memo to media outlets you correctly
would get allegations that this is an
instance of government trying to
suppress people Spri people's speech
limit the freedom of press outlets to
decide completely by themselves who they
should and shouldn't have on and that's
a very specific reason why we are
getting this from the twenty20 trump
campaign rather than the Trump White
House now let me talk about a different
type of censorship that's going on I
would actually direct media outlets
anytime you have a former Trump
associate of whether it's from Trump's
political administration whether it's
from Trump's business whatever we know
that they are forced by Donald Trump to
sign these oppressive non-disclosure
agreements so what I would like to see
is anytime a current or former Trump
astiz brought on to corporate media say
to them have you signed a non-disclosure
and or non-disparagement agreement that
limits what you're allowed to say today
because knowing that would actually be
the responsible thing for media to do
are you able to say whatever you want
today or are you limited by a
non-disclosure or a non-disparagement
agreement with any Trump affiliated
entity and if the answer is yes then we
should all understand that they are
bound by a legal document restricting
their speech which Donald Trump made
them sign on
think we're going to see that and
hopefully we're also not going to see
media outlets sort of bow to this
request from the Trump campaign it's
chilling it's yet another one of these
authoritarian tendencies and I think
that as usual Pat it's another instance
of projection everything that the Trump
administration accuses others of in this
case media interviewing people who
spread this information I mean turn on
Fox and Friends that's all it is yeah
and if you take a look at the list of
names they also have quotes attributed
to them and these quotes are apparently
reasons why they should not be invited
back on news programs and they're
totally lackluster like the one for Adam
Schiff it says I think there's plenty of
evidence of collusion or conspiracy in
plain sight first of all he says I think
right so he's expressing his opinion
there and second I mean evidence of
collusion in plain sight you could
attribute that to the Trump Tower
meeting right I mean we for a long time
have been talking about whether this is
collusion that rises to the degree of
conspiracy to defraud the United States
and that would be a big charge
ultimately we didn't get that from the
Moller report but to say that what Adam
Schiff was said was totally wrong there
that's just not true completely
uncontroversial comment from Adam Schiff
there is evidence of collusion plain as
day he's not saying that that is
criminal collusion he is saying that
that's what he sees and that's what he
believes and I mean can you imagine
saying someone can't be allowed back on
media or shouldn't be allowed back on
media outlets because they express their
very sensible opinion on the basis of
what was publicly known at the time and
and by the way my last thought on this
I've been pushing asking imploring the
press corps the White House press corps
to hold Sarah Huckabee Sanders to the
standard that apparently now the Trump
campaign wants democratic elected
officials held to by corporate media
Sarah Huckabee Sanders is the one who
actually should be scrutinized in the
way that it appears the 2020 Trump
campaign is demanding media outlets do
of democratic and other anti-trump
forces I guess this ultimately comes
down to Donald Trump is feeling sort of
audacious riding high
the emotion of william bars bogus
four-page letter which Trump claims or
actually believes fully exonerates him
and hopefully no media outlets will
actually follow through with this the
David Pakman show is on instagram at
david pakman show follow us there back
after this one of our sponsors today is
minds.com mines is a social networking
platform that combines many features
that are similar to what you find on
platforms like YouTube or Facebook or
Twitter like news feeds groups videos
blogging except what makes mines
different is their goal of maintaining
free speech transparency user privacy
and ensuring that users are fairly
compensated for the content they create
this has been an issue for the David
Pakman show
most other major social networking
companies are secretive about their
algorithms all of the code that drives
the minds social network is free and
it's open source anybody can access it
and see how the platform operates and
contribute to the project they're sort
of taking the same open-source
principles behind something like
Wikipedia where everything is totally
open and transparent and instead
applying it to social media where you
usually don't see it they also have a
very free speech oriented content policy
everything on the site is encrypted your
data stays safe mine's doesn't track
what you're doing online the way many
other platforms do lots of other sites
give you privacy settings but that
doesn't change the fact that they still
have access to your private data but
with the encryption on mines mines
doesn't even have the ability to read
your private messages or whatever else
you're doing and every time you do
something on mines like post content or
share or like someone else's content you
earn mines tokens which can then be used
to boost the visibility of the content
that you create and post I encourage you
to go check it out at minds.com there's
also a mobile app and you can actually
follow the david pakman show on mines at
minds.com slash david pakman show I've
also put a link right underneath this
video